[Musica]
quanto tempo ci impiega ad accorgersi
che sono qua
[Applauso]
esattamente un minuto e 10 secondi dai
allora ragazzi c'è un tempo di merda
visto che è mattina e i Pantellas stanno
ancora dormendo Sto andando al senza
oggi tempo il tempio senso oggi e il
tempio più antico di Tokyo è come potete
vedere ragazzi è full of turisti
mannaggia oh Vabbè Eh si fa quel che si
può raga Madonna quanto sta piovendo
incre Meno male che sono partito con
roba abbastanza pesante perché ho
previsto tutto e ve lo ricorderete
Sicuramente ma io non entro l'anno c'è
la gente dentro di qua me ne fotto me ne
fotto No scherzo Ragazzi io me lo
ricordi in realtà è veramente suggestivo
Il panorama che si vede da qui di solito
ma ci sono solo ombrelli c'è una fila
interminabile di ombrelli
non si vede nulla nulla cosmico è
peccato perché ci sono un sacco di
bancarelle carine le vedi solo quando ci
sei dentro praticamente Ed eccoci qua my
boys senza oggi tempo per una cosa a
caso capito Io non so se vendono Non so
perché magari è un sacri
io me lo comprerei istantaneamente Non
penso ci sia perché Madonna ma è
bellissimo dentro c'è anche una parte
dentro pazzesca sembra un po' La città
incantata Aspetta che vado Eccolo
bellissimo Ecco questa parte interna è
pazzesca c'è la pagoda No ragazzi è
incredibile è veramente incredibile Oh
così mi vedete bene come son conciato
hai così che mi vede la gente sembra
proprio un [__] Allora ragazzi al
sensushi tempo siamo ancora qua facciamo
un Japan taste e invece prende la Evian
o acque a caso prendiamola nachow Mirror
testiamo ragazzi
sa di rito ancestrale Dato la vista cioè
è con questo posto Non ha senso ragazzi
Cioè questo è uno dei miei posti
preferiti al mondo è incredibile Ok
ragazzi siamo finiti a shibuya a shibuya
c'è il Nintendo Store di fianco al
Pokémon Center che è pazzesco Perché uno
è enorme e l'altro ancora più grosso
questo penso sia il più grande Pokémon
Center di Tokyo non vedi una cazzata eh
Comunque io spendo tutti i miei soldi
qui dentro ragazzi non saprei nemmeno
che cosa inquadrarvi per prima a parte
che questo è il punto del merchandising
del team di Super Mario va bene
boh cioè non so non so
Tieni due telefoni adesso ti devo
doppiare il tizio
grazie
ad alto livello ragazzi
come toccare una tetta no no no no no
non può essere questo è un coso di Lego
di Bowser Adesso ti faccio vedere la
cosa più [__] di tutto il centro
commerciale oh oh
Non è vero
Ma che cazzo dici
Ma che cazzo dici Ma cosa hai fatto
benissimo No vabbè no vabbè non so che
dire
è fatto benissimo e poi Ragazzi c'è la
parte Sound del Pokémon Center dove tu
clicchi la mano e quello ti fa il suono
però Sei incredibile noi provare questa
è la Battle
[Musica]
Va bene
Ciao ragazzi Abbiamo chiesto a J di
portarci a cena J e qua non si vede
Infatti Ecco non i capelli
[Musica]
avevo chiesto di portarci a cena e già
ci ha portati qua ecco qua ho portato la
candela che ci sono delle Marta queste J
e questa è il nostro posto dove ceniamo
che mi sembra tutto fuorché
dove si possa cenare Gemma che cazzo hai
capito siamo arrivati a questo momento
di merda e fare il test il testing di
cibo italiano all'estero Siccome ho
provato la pizza all'ananas in America
oggi Proviamo la pizza punto già già a
mettere meno input meno input pizza
punto Margherita in Giappone che questa
brillantezza qua
già dall'odore sa di ergastolo Però
vediamo se riusciamo a ingurgitarla
No dai è terribile
[Musica]
anch'io però Minchia è terribile dai da
1 a 10 Lido 4 di più ci sono dei video
sul mio canale che possono essere
reputati leggendari Particolari video
che hanno fatto la differenza uno di
questi è l'ultra Japan in Giappone che è
ultra Music Festival Se conoscete il
Festival di EM tipo il Tomorrowland che
fanno appunto in Giappone questo
festival ha luogo a dodaiba che questa
isola artificiale di Tokyo dove c'è il
giga Gundam e oggi sono tornato a
lodaiba che non ho mai visto se non nel
contesto dell'ultra Japan quindi senza
l'ultra Japan non so che cazzo ci sia a
dodaiba però due o tre cose molto
carucce ci sono come ad esempio il
Gundam di cui vi parlavo prima che è
questo qua Mentre lì dove state vedendo
in questo momento quello spiazzo là là
facevano l'ultra Japan mi fa stranissimo
vederlo vuoto Tra l'altro ragazzi oggi
C'è un cielo che non esiste bellissimo
ma che storia sto giugno come sono
gasato Guarda Molo scalo da dietro e ci
entro dentro secondo me funziona
comunque ragazzi non so se Dal video si
percepisce Però a me sembra che il
Giappone abbia un filtro tipo di quelli
Instagram applicato proprio già di suo
Cioè non vedete che i colori sono
diversi da quelli dell'Italia per dire
non so se dal telefono si percepisce
cioè io quando guardo in giro mi sembra
di avere un filtro davanti agli occhi
cioè strano e poi ci sta giga supposta
Ma perché non mi spiego niente di quello
che vedo Madonna Raga ma che punto
panoramico di Cristo che è questo c'è
una spiaggia ma di cosa stiamo parlando
di cosa parliamo mi può portare anche a
me giù così La prego Ok ragazzi penso di
aver trovato a cazzo il posto migliore
di tutta Tokyo va bene che lo store
dello Studio Ghibli ed è qui che finisce
il mio patrimonio No ma signore vabbè
vabbè
Vabbè non posso neanche comprarli Perché
dove li metto compro una valigia di
Totoro ci ficco le cose dentro e là
imbarco non lo so E ho deciso il mio
acquisto signori che è questo
portamonete di Totoro che cosa più o
meno 30 euro costa tutto un sacco ma
credo che ne valga la pena Ed eccoci qui
con i nostri soldi buttati nel cesso
però ne è valsa la pena e siamo arrivati
alla Gundam base
che
Allora non sono fan di Gundam mai stato
Cioè a me i robottoni non mi sono mai
troppo piaciuti eh tranne vabbè evangeli
ma quanti Gundam giganti abbiamo visto
da quando siamo qua un casino se ci fate
caso incredibile Cioè addirittura con
gli effetti qua Vabbè ci stiamo
superando ragazzi va bene e anche questo
tour è finito bello bello Questo è il
centro commerciale che sta dietro al
Gundam Fighissimo molto figo Eccoli qua
I magici in coda da zio Peppe ragazzi
che dire Siamo in Giappone
io non so come sia possibile ma siamo in
Giappone Siamo da zio Peppe Ma perché
dico zio ma non lo so Vieni da dire zio
Zio Peppe sarà uno zio Questo qua è
Peppe Sanna è pesante facciamo vedere
Peppe Sandro
ragazzi non so come sia possibile Peppe
Sanna ricordatevelo che fa pizza buona a
Tokyo e siamo Come di consueto in cima
alla doppio Tower spendendo il doppio
del biglietto come sempre ragazzi come
sempre già fatto questo video ma
Però una volta nella vita si vede tutto
perché abbiamo deciso stavolta al giorno
che non sono stronzo stavolta ho scelto
il giorno in cui si vede per l'ultima
volta non si vedevano nu cazz ai video
vecchio che avevo fatto in Giappone qua
si vede grazie a Dio allora Pensavo
fosse più ansia Oggi no invece sono
abbastanza tranquillo salendo sulla
Shield invece no Mi sto cagando addosso
trash Queen
Crush
alone Come mai ci sono pochi cestini
dell'immondizia
prima di first dancer
Just in the station il bluetooth
I can però
spunta la bomba Ok
allora informazione è molto importante
Praticamente ho capito ho capito tutti
hanno capito
le bomba nel cestino quindi molto
pericoloso Speriamo che non la mettono
pure nei cessi perché poi è peggio
potrebbe essere un problema Sì
bonjours altro giorno altro dolore ai
piedi ovviamente Comunque stavo
valutando mi sta piacendo molto questa
vacanza Un po' diversa rispetto al
solito perché abbiamo un albergo che è
molto occidentale no Quindi ragionavo
sul fatto che effettivamente a me che
piace la cultura giapponese l'albergo
deve essere parte integrante
dell'experience quindi avere l'albergo
un po' occidentale ti spezza un po' quel
Mood giapponese che vorresti vedere no
che Vabbè Esci e ce l'hai Però sai anche
l'albergo fa parte in percentuale del
20%
dell'experience perché comunque ci dormi
un po' ci passi del tempo e quindi sei
giapponese anche quello è meglio
Diversamente dai che ne so l'America
Cioè chi se ne frega la cultura degli
americani è quella quindi va bene Ok
ragazzi sono arrivato a shinjuku dei
Pantellas non c'è traccia Nel senso che
sono in albergo a dormire e non li ho
ancora sentiti quindi penso che siano
morti e sono qua da sola shinjuku non
sono venuto andare a shibuya dove c'è
l'incrocio quello lì dentro lì si
Mordano E comunque vabbè vedi incrocio
famoso di shibuya perché vorrei andarci
con loro Siccome anche molto vicino a
dare acuco che è un quartiere super figo
dove vendono un sacco di cose si può
arrivare anche a piedi dall'uno
all'altro Quindi vorrei andare lì con
loro Allora io ho detto vabbè stamattina
vado a shinjuku che a mezz'ora di metro
solo che non mi ricordo che cazzo c'è a
Shield tu cioè mi ricordo che è figo ma
non mi ricordo perché poverini sono
tashing gioco Vediamo cosa trovo Ok
ragazzi Diciamo che adesso mi ricordo
che cosa c'è la Shield Google adesso me
lo ricordo è tutto chiaro nella mia
testa uno tende a dimenticare Come
faccio a dimenticarmi ste cose non lo so
mi conviene portare i Pantellas qua
senza avvertirli vedere che che dicono
secondo me un po' male si pigliano
soprattutto la mezza addormentati Eccoli
qua anima maestri Eccoli Guarda c'è un
utile possiamo fare un si può fare un
multiverso qua potreste stringervi la
mano noi due per favore
una volta sola Grazie
Ecco qua
Marvel Cinematic Universe Eh no Minchia
già il 2 già Il sequel Vabbè siamo
arrivati a Yokohama che è questa che è
questa fine perché c'è Mar De Napoli Qui
ci sta un mare fuori ma
Esatto la smetti di fare sti Zombie vi
dà fastidio nei video insomma Sì ma
infatti io continuo a farli Comunque no
sono felice oggi non so se si vede
perché ho dormito Minchia l'unico giorno
in cui ho dormito Madonna vorrei
comprare tutto quello che c'è qua dentro
ma le scarpe Dove metto le lasciano qua
sotto dove le lascio lì
Com'è andata benissimo ho scassato un
ginocchio
Ah vuoi fare Il close up Va bene io
faccio i video di merda Allora oggi
facciamo quelli che mangiano la carne
cruda si prende con Come si chiama la
presina si mette sopra si aspettano
8 ore qualche minuto e poi la tiri e la
mangi
Allora ragazzi è arrivato un momento che
nella mia vita è importante fare il test
del gelato italiano in Giappone Luca ha
manga che sta riprendendo lo vedrà dalla
mia espressione
o è pazzesco giuro su Dio Vuoi
assaggiare incredibile
sto scherzando
è veramente buono
[Musica]
a posto
Come si usano le cose come si usano
prova qui Mario botanico
[Applauso]
[Musica]
le pinze
cos'era qua la faccia del vincitore
Perfetto grazie grazie
andiamo a vedere un Gundam Ok non vi ho
introdotto questa cosa siamo a vedere un
Gundam ma non è piccolo è grosso ma
grosso forte Guarda che roba
affacciazzerò Questo è giapponese
Incredibile incredibile
ma come hanno fatto a fare questa cosa
ragazzi dal video non si percepisce è
titanico è veramente un cazzo di Gundam
incredibile e grossissimo ma Raga ma è
pazzesco cioè una roba spaventosa donna
smantellarla al mese scorso Quindi è un
evento il fatto che ci sia ancora noi la
stiamo vedendo per ultimi praticamente
erano per sempre gran culo abbiamo avuto
oggi
[__] Gundam di 8000 metri ok
no anche fa impressione
[Musica]
Allora l'effetto sonoro del pazzo che ha
fatto Vabbè dopo questa Mistica
esperienza di Gundam stiamo approcciando
Il magico Pokémon Center tutti mi avete
scritto Bayern Sì lo so queste cultura
lo sappiamo e la esploriamo andiamo
andiamo Eccoci qua very nice Grazie di
averci portato qua a papà Madonna
ragazzi gigante ragazzi voglio morire
qua si può avevo fatto Se vi ricordate i
tempi un vlog sempre sul Pokémon Sam
sempre in un Pokémon Center qua in
Giappone era molto simile perché
comunque sono tutti più o meno dello
stesso stampo però questo incredibile
Questo è molto più grosso cioè l'altro
era più piccolo questo gigante
fighissimo ragazzi fighissimo e vorrei
tutto
[Musica]
Cosa stai guardando
Mamma mia quanto siamo brutti in culo
Ciao ragazzi non so se vi ricordate ma
nel 2016 o 17 ero andato a mangiare in
un sushi va fatto il blog un sushi che
praticamente è un sushi che ha il
trenino ma è inutile che ve lo spiego ve
lo faccio vedere perché siamo qua in
questo preciso momento c'è una coda
della Madonna ma noi Aspetteremo perché
questo posto merita vedrete Eccoci qua
ragazzi siamo seduti al Ah sono qua sono
già arrivati cazzo ti è arrivato anche
il tuo Ok perfetto e poi si ripigliamo i
piatti ma qua non lo ordinato Io ok e se
ne va
lui ha capito che non è suo e se ne sta
andando praticamente ragazzi Noi abbiamo
questo tablet e abbiamo due binari dei
treni sopra il tablet noi scegliamo il
cibo
e poi andiamo su Order è il cibo ci
arriva direttamente qua come vi farò
vedere tra qualche istante ordine Eccolo
qua
merci se siamo un po' delle scrofe
perché mangeremo 6000 piatti però vabbè
è arrivato un cocktail che non ha
ordinato verde tipo Slime e adesso la
assaggerà
poggiato un drink che non l'ha ordinato
Che poi perde vomito cioè di Cosa sai di
vomito diverso
è letteralmente uscito da Toy Story
questo drink ma prova a assaggiarlo sì
fammi assaggiare anche a me kryptonite
liquida no È indescrivibile non è una
roba che puoi bere col sushi te lo posso
assicurare prova è Monte indiu quella
ti assicuro Ma tipo Red Bull è una
Mountain View Sì
col sushi Allora ragazzi siamo al
Godzilla hotel che non si chiama
Godzilla hotel Ma vabbè qualcosa di
simile dentro c'è questo vi assicuro che
è grosso
[Musica]
dovrebbe essere in cima all'albergo e
c'è la testa di Godzilla quella che si
vede nella strada famosissima di
shinjuku Adesso dovremmo essere in cima
Vediamo cosa succede se non è
incredibile Eccoci qua ha effettivamente
funzionato incredibile per una volta
abbiamo un'idea e funziona C'è la testa
di Godzilla Siamo in cima e qua si
dovrebbe vedere tutta shinjuku adesso
vediamo questa è la main Road
queste Godzilla che
mi sta ruttando in faccia Vabbè comunque
molto figo ragazzi faccio una chiusa
mentre sono al centro di shinjuku Ma chi
se ne frega Io volevo ringraziarvi per
aver visto questo vlog ci vediamo
appunto nei prossimi giorni con il
prossimo vlog sul Giappone perché sto
registrando tutto quanto come potete
vedere ragazzi mi sto mi sto impegnando
anche per fare questa cosa ma questa
cosa mi fa troppo piacere come vi ho
scritto nei commenti del video
precedente mi sta facendo molto piacere
documentarvi tutto questo viaggio quindi
per me è solo un'emozione incredibile
giusta per la quarta volta perché la
quarta volta che vengo in Giappone ma
condivisa con voi vale doppio
Ma quanto sono Ateneo perché cagata
parte iscrivetevi al canale ragazzi
lasciate un bel commento mi piace e noi
come sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo
video
dove cazzo son finito